he was the quiet efficient and oh so
ruthless architect of the Holocaust
Hitler's most loyal sycophants he
ruthlessly dispatched those who stood in
his way as he rose to a position of
power that was second only to that of
the Fuhrer in the end he spectacularly
betrayed his master only to be felled by
his own hands
in this episode of biographic s-- we
reveal the cold calculating life and the
death of Heinrich Himmler
Henryk leupold Himmler was born on
October the 7th 1980 Lukas Strauss - in
Munich he was the second of three sons
to Gabe Haas and anna-marie Himmler
Gebhardt was the deputy headmaster of
landshort high school and was a pious
and pedantic man the family were
well-off but they weren't rich and they
held a measure of prestige in the local
community Gerhardt had previously been
the tutor to the Royal wittelsbach
princes it was this connection that led
to the great honor of having prince
heinrich of Bavaria as Heinrichs
godfather heinrich was not a well child
he was often absent from school with one
illness or another still he made up for
the absences by simply working harder by
doing so he proved himself to be an
excellent student a middle school
teacher remembered him as a very keen
pupil whose tireless application burning
ambition and active participation in
class have achieved excellent results
the man who would go on to persecute the
Catholic clergy without mercy grew up as
part of a devout family of believers as
a youth he wrote in his diary I will
always love God and remain true to the
church as a teenager Heinrich served as
an altar boy but when war broke out he
developed a desire to serve his country
in a military capacity get part a
further nationalist approved and tried
to use his royal contacts to smooth his
son's path to becoming an officer
however the seventeen-year-old was
turned down by the imperial navy due to
his short sightedness he therefore
turned to the army gaining entry and
being sent to officer training school
but before he had completed his
cadetship the war it was over
unlike the Fuehrer who he would come to
greatly admire him ler saw none of the
carnage of the great war firsthand
[Music]
in April 1919 Himmler joins one of the
many Freikorps army units that were
determined to crush the communist
movements during the next two years he
served in various paramilitary
organizations that were on the march
against democracy the shameful Treaty of
Versailles and Marxist dictatorship
young Himmler had been frustrated that
he didn't get to fight on the front
lines during the war and lacking any
direction he sought a cause that he
could embrace and a leader that he could
respect
Himmler's family had not been inherently
anti-semitic in his early 20s however he
began reading the Jew bashing pamphlets
that was circulating around nunik he
also got a hold of the protocols of the
Elders of Zion they faked documents the
purported to contain details of a Jewish
world conspiracy Himmler came of age in
a time when the old order of things was
in a state of chaos the German people
they were defeated their economy
decimated and their psyche damaged
irreparably this caused a lot of fear
and a lot of depression in the old order
Himmler the son of a royal tutor would
have found a secure place in society but
now all bets were off he would have to
forge his own path Gerhard Himmler had
instilled in his sons the teutonic ideal
that the German Aryan was the master
human being what Heinrich saw on the
streets of Munich in the early 20s was
the opposite of Aryan supremacy the
people were fast sliding into decadence
and immorality but this was no fault of
the German people his readings convinced
Himmler that the country's ills could be
laid at the feet of one group and that
was of course the Jews hem Lowood spends
the rest of his life championing the
Teutonic ideal his constant refrain when
faced with a situation was what would
our forefathers have done in this
situation disgusted at what had happened
to his beloved German nation the young
him that began making a plan to emigrate
on November the 23rd 1921 he wrote the
following in his diary today I cut an
article from the newspaper about
immigration to Peru where I will end up
Spain Turkey the Baltic countries Russia
Peru I often think about it in two years
time I will no longer be in Germany now
a year later he was still in Germany but
the dream of living abroad it was still
with him
in 1922 he inquired at the Soviet
embassy about moving to the Ukraine as
an estate manager interestingly two
decades later he would send his death
squads into Ukraine to decimate the land
and wipe out its Jewish inhabitants but
for now his greatest ambition was to be
a peaceful agricultural manager well by
the end of 1922 Himmler had completed a
degree in agriculture and settled into a
job as an agricultural assistant in a
fertilizer factory then in 1923 he joins
the nationalist Socialist Workers Party
also known as the Nazi Party he started
off as a member of the paramilitary unit
under Ernst röhm and played a part in
the unsuccessful Beer Hall Putsch in an
attempt to seize power
the police threw several people
including Hitler himself in prison
Himmler he was questioned but he was
released because of lack of evidence but
his involvement in the attempted revolt
led him to losing his job as an
agricultural analyst with no money
coming in he had to move back in with
his parents around this time Himmler
appears to have fallen into a depressive
state he had a few friends and portrayed
an aggressive volcanic personality the
Catholic religion which had been so dear
to him was abandoned and a fascination
with the occult began to take shape
unlike a lot of other new recruits to
the Nazi Party and that was not
immediately overawed by the presence of
a toff Hitler this adoration that he had
for the Fuehrer it developed over a long
time as was his nature Himmler read
everything he could about and by Hitler
he came to appreciate him first on an
intellectual level he worship that would
come soon enough
[Music]
viii now unemployed twenty-five-year-old
began putting all of his energies into
the cause of a national socialism he
took on the position of secretary for
Gregor Strasser a pharmacist from
landshort who was standing as a
candidate for the Reichstag in return
for a salary of 120 Reichsmarks he
traveled around to lower bavaria on his
motorcycle and gave inflammatory
speeches against Jews and communists
Strasser was a Nazi Party member who was
attempting to wrest control of the
organization from the imprisoned Hitler
believing that he would succeed him
Allah supported Strasser in this
internal power struggle in the early
1920s the notoriously shy Heinrich found
his Fraulein a nurse from Bromberg named
Marga tall blond and blue-eyed she
fitted the Teutonic ideal and matched
Himmler's ideal image of Germanic
womanhood the couple were married on
July the 3rd 1928 with Marga bringing a
sizeable dowry to the Union the
financial windfall enabled Heinrich to
realize his dream of owning his own
piece of land and they purchased a
chicken farm not far from Munich during
this time Himmler managed to rise
rapidly and standing within the party by
1926 he was deputy head of Reich
propaganda and then deputy reichsfuhrer
SS by then Hitler had been released from
prison brushed aside the internal threat
from Strasser and published his term
mine camp Himmler effortlessly switched
his allegiance back to Hitler he
devoured mine Kampf commenting that it
contained an extraordinary number of
truths very quickly
Himmler's loyalty to Hitler it became
absolute
[Music]
by the mid-1920s Hitler came to the
realization that he was in need of a
special protection force he needed a
squad of men who gave him unquestioned
loyalty and were even prepared to march
against their brothers if need be to
head such a force no one was as
fervently devoted and therefore so
eminently suited as Heinrich Himmler on
January the 61920 nine Hitler appointed
Himmler to the position of reichsfuhrer
SS at that time the SS was a small
division of the larger SA which was
under the headship of Ernst röhm the SA
was Hitler's private army the fighting
quality of its men was questionable but
Rahm saw its strength coming from force
of numbers in contrast the SS was a far
more elite force its members wore black
peaked caps emblazoned with a skull
along with black bordered swastika
armbands this new position it was ideal
for Himmler since his youth he had been
fascinated by the elite Praetorian
guards that were the elite protection
force of Roman emperors now he had the
opportunity to craft his own modern-day
praetorian guard he immediately began
putting his own stamp on the SS he had
belt buckles made that were scripted
with the words SS man
loyalty is they honor he also came up
with a succinct motto for his men be
more than you seem
when Himmler assumes leadership the SS
numbered around 200 men a year later it
had grown to just over a thousand by
June of 1934 it had swollen to 50,000
men in 1931 Himmler created a unit
within that unit and it was called 1c
and it was put under the leadership of a
rising star called Reinhard Heydrich
later to become the Secret Service this
was the organ by which Hitler could have
undercover surveillance undertaken
within the party
by 1934 the SA under Ernst röhm had
become redundant Hitler now that he was
Chancellor he had no need for a bunch of
street thugs in fact his association
with them was bound to be damaging to
his career it was time to break this
private army up Himmler was delighted
with the news that the SA along with its
commander and Strom were about to be
dealt with for five years he had been a
subordinate to the uncouth and
disorganized Rahm whom he considered his
social inferior Himmler threw himself
into planning the overthrow of the SA
that history would recall as the night
of the Long Knives documents before to
show that the SA was planning a coup and
Himmler personally took these documents
to hit that immediately death lists were
drawn up containing the names of SA
leaders as well as any others who were
seen by Himmler and Heydrich as threats
to their growing power at the top of
that list was Ernst röhm when Rome was
taken into custody Hillier was actually
in favor of commuting the death sentence
of his long term colleague but he was
browbeaten by Himmler and Heydrich into
eliminating him this was in calling with
Himmler's underlying nature he was a man
who was completely devoid of scruples
lacking any of the normal inhibitions or
pangs of conscience that would cause
others to pause in such actions the
arrests torment and murders of the night
of the Long Knives were carried out by
Himmler's SS their leader well he was a
major beneficiary of this operation in
the wake of the purging of the SA
Himmler took over headship of the
Gestapo from Hermann Goering around that
same time Himmler ordered the death of
Gerard Strasser the man he had earlier
supported as Nazi Party leader and who
had been his employer
[Music]
by 1935 Himmler was in a position of
great power within the Nazi state as
well as heading the SS and the Gestapo
he was also in command of the entire
German police force this allowed him to
participate in cabinet meetings with all
the rights and privileges afforded a
minister of the Reich on October the
11th 1936 Himmler gave a speech in front
of the academy of German law in it he
made it clear how he was going to run
the country's police and defense forces
whether or not our actions conflict with
a particular article or subsection is a
matter of complete indifference to me in
the fulfilment of my duty I do precisely
what I can answer form in my work for
Fuhrer and nation and what equates with
healthy common sense whether or not
others whined about a breach of the law
is no concern to me
hello was only except the very best
atonic men into the SS the organization
was to be a racial elite class Himmler
made sure that he saw a photo of every
applicants he meticulously scans them in
search of anything that might give
evidence of impurity once he found his
perfect specimens he intended to do what
he could to ensure that there were more
of them and so on October the 28th 1939
he issued his procreation order to the
SS it was the highest duty of women and
girls to conceive children by soldiers
of the SS before they went into battle
in other words if a female did not
submit to the sexual demands of an SS
man she was guilty of treason to the
state an alert became obsessed with the
idea of procreating the world with pure
Aryans an order went out that every SS
man was to father at least one child he
considered monogamy to be a sin his men
were allowed to have several wives in
order to be able to father as many
future heroes as possible
[Music]
under Himmler VSS became much more than
a personal bodyguard for the Fuehrer
Himmler had been charged with restoring
the nation to health this task required
ridding the country of racial impurity
to do this the SS would go through
community after community and cleanse it
of Jews freemasons and Jesuits but
Himmler had soon extended the list of
undesirables to include Slavs
gypsies homosexuals jehovah's witnesses
and communists when Hitler invaded
Russia in 1941 Himmler provided action
squads who would follow up the Regular
Army as it conquered the lands their job
was to take out all Jews communists and
gypsies Himmler ensured that his men
kept meticulous records of their
activities one of the squad commanders
had recorded 90,000 killings in just the
last few months of 1941 these masks are
murders however presented a problem that
Himmler had to provide a solution for
having to kill so many people each day
was proving challenging for the psyches
of the soldiers doing the work the
question that entered his mind was was
there a more efficient way to kill that
did not lead to such demoralization now
of course there was no question in
Himmler's mind that the course of mass
murder was morally socially and
politically correct for years he had
drilled two simple rules into the minds
of his SS firstly the Fuhrer was always
right and secondly the end justifies the
means he presented the mass
extermination as a monumental secular
mission that his men were privileged to
be fulfilling after personally watching
the execution of 200 Jews near Minsk he
said it is the curse of the great man to
step over corpses in the summer of 1941
Himmler summons the commandant of the
Auschwitz concentration camp Rudolf höss
to a meeting in Berlin he informed him
that the Fuhrer had ordered the final
solution of the Jewish Question the SS
he told Haas where to carry out that
order and he had selected outfits as the
prime location to do it austan out of
Eichmann were to organize the genocide
that Himmler
was the man in charge under him was
watchful gaze the concentration camps
with a schvitz as the shining model
became incredibly efficient death
factories those passing through the
gates of the camp were weeded with those
selected going directly to the gas
chambers unless
than 15 minutes they were dead victims
of the highly poisonous gas zyklon-b
for those who were considered fit for
work their death would come from
exhaustion or starvation Himmler paid a
personal visit - Fitz in 1942 he watched
as victims were selected and watched
through a spy hole in the gas chamber
door as the executions were carried out
he did not comment on what he saw which
was assigned to commandant Haase that he
was happy with what he witnessed he went
on to inspect the rest of the camp
during which time Haase campaigns about
the squalid conditions and the dangers
of disease to his men Himmler stopped
him in mid-sentence and declared I don't
want to hear any more about your
difficulties for an SS officer there are
no difficulties his duty is always to
remove difficulties himself as soon as
they arise how you do it is for you to
figure out not me
by mid 1944 the tide of warp had turned
and the writing was on the wall for the
Nazi regime yet Himmler's unwavering
loyalty to Adolphe Hitler was still
intact this being the case historians
have noted that it does seem odd that
with his massive spy network he did not
have advanced warnings of the July 20th
1944 plot to kill Hitler some have even
speculated that he was involved in some
way now it is true the three days before
the attack he turned down a written
Gestapo request for permission to arrest
two of the main plotters it's also clear
that the ruthlessness with which the SS
persecution machine went into action
after the attack was not matched with
it's usually impeccable standard of
surveillance before it it is probable
that him that did not intend to betray
Hitler on July the 20th 1944 but that
betrayal it was to come and it would
manifest itself on the Fuehrer's
birthday April the 20th 1945 on that day
Himmler was a guest along with other
high-ranking Nazis at what must surely
have been one of the most macabre
birthday parties in history it was held
in the underground bunker that was
hitler's final hideout situated in the
heart of ravaged Berlin Hitler was
unaware that Himmler had a second
engagement later that day with an
emissary from the World Congress of
Jewry he proposed that the Jews and the
National Socialists bury the hatchet and
the concentration camp inmates would be
handed over to the Red Cross just a few
days earlier he had given orders that no
camp survivors were to fall into enemy
hands and no camps were to be
surrendered his about-face was clearly a
matter of expediency in an attempt to
minimize the ire of the Allies when they
discovered the horrors that had been
taking place under his watch
three days later Himmler held talks with
the Swedish diplomat count folke
Bernadotte a here he presented a
surprising offer saying that in order to
save Germans from the full force of a
Russian invasion he was prepared to
surrender the Western Front but not the
Eastern Front Himmler believed that he
could negotiate directly with President
Eisenhower and wondered out loud whether
he should shake the president's hand or
offer him and Nazi salute of course
Himmler's clandestine visits were meant
to be top secret however somehow they
got leaked to the media Ren's on April
the 28th London's BBC broadcast that
Himmler was claiming that Hitler was
dead and that he was his successor in
the Berlin bunker there was monitoring
the hour
and this news well it soon found its way
to the Fuhrer Hitler was dumbstruck he
could accept betrayal from anyone else
but never from his loyal Himmler he
called it the most monstrous betrayal in
world history and he immediately ordered
Himmler's arrest but within days Hitler
he was dead the victim of his own hands
[Music]
on May the 1st Himmler met with Hitler's
air Admiral Karl dönitz at the naval
barracks at Plum units was wary even
though Himmler had been deposed there
was no telling how much allegiance the
men of the SS would still give to him
Himmler was shown his letter of
dismissal ignoring at sea congratulated
dönitz on his appointments and offered
to work with him as his
second-in-command
dönitz declined the meeting was over and
Himmler was allowed to walk away he now
resolved to go into hiding and bide his
time before coming back to lead his
all-powerful SS on a surge to power on
may the 22nd with the war over and
Germany under Allied occupation a
British patrol spotted a group of ragged
looking men outside of Hamburg one of
them a short thin man with a black eye
patch told them his name was Heinrich
hit Singam and then produced forged
identity papers he was dressed as an
ordinary German soldier the seven men
were in fact Himmler and his bodyguards
the British guards took the group into
custody and placed them in a prisoner of
war camp just outside of Bremen it
didn't take long for the proud Himmler
to chafe under the common treatment that
he was receiving as merely a captured
soldier after a few days he requested an
audience with the camp commander
expecting to be treated with newfound
dignity Himmler announced his true
identity but rather than being respected
for his position as the Nazi number two
men his captors treated him with
contempt he was forced to strip
completely and kept under 24-hour watch
to prevent his suicide the following day
Himmler was brought before the camp
commander for interrogation in his mouth
he had secret is an ampule of poison
which had been issued to all top Nazis
in which they always carried with them a
body search was ordered and when the
doctor tried to examine Himmler's mouth
he bit down on the ampule the enraged
British tried desperately to clear the
poison from his system but it was no
good within 12 minutes Himmler was dead
so I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographic if you did there's
a couple of things you could do right
now one is hit that like button below
also if you want more stuff like this we
put out brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always
thank you for watching
you